oh robotics people i love you so much
this is the i i i could i could talk
forever about this but yes there's a
technology problem let's focus on that
we'll figure out the actual
uh impact on society how it's actually
going to be applied how it's actually
going to be integrated from a policy and
from a human perspective from a business
perspective later first let's solve the
technology problem that's not how life
works friends but okay i'm sorry yeah
yeah so i mean i mean i'm sure you know
the division of labor in these companies
right there's sort of a business
development side you know and then
there's the engineering side right and
the engineers are like oh my god what
are these business development people
you know why are they involved you know
sort of like
in this process so i ended up sort of
coming up with a few different ideas
that people seem to be batting around
and then really try to zero in on a
layman's understanding of the
limitations right and
it it turns out that's really obvious
and and quite simple
highway driving's a lot simpler right um
so you know the the plan is simplify the
problem right um and focus on highways
because city driving is is so um so much
more complicated
so
from that i i came up with basically six
scenarios actually i came up with five
that the developers were talking about
and then one that i thought was a good
idea that i had read about um i think in
like 2013 or 2014
which was actually something that the us
military was looking at
i actually first heard about the idea of
this kind of automation at least in in
in sketched out form in like 2011 i
guess it was with peloton which was this
sort of early technology entrant into
the trucking industry which was working
on platooning platooning trucks
and and all they were doing was you know
a cooperative adaptive cruise control as
they they came to call it um
and we ended up on a panel together and
it's it's kind of interesting because i
was on that panel because
i was thinking about how we got the best
return on investment for fuel-efficient
technologies and if it's cool i'll sort
of set set this up because it does it
comes into sort of the story of some of
these scenarios um so
when i studied the drivers you had this
like
complete difference in
the driving tasks
like we were talking about before with
long haul and city right and
you're not paid in the city you've got
congestion the turns are tight
um there's lots of you know pedestrians
you know all the things that
self-driving trucks don't like truckers
don't like right and they're not paid
there's lots of waiting time and then in
the highway they get to cruise they're
getting paid they have control they go
at their own pace they're making money
they're happy
well it turned out right i guess it was
around 2010 this is still when we were
thinking about regenerative braking you
know and hybrid trucks being sort of
like the solution
um
the
problems with them sort of and the
advantages you know also split on what i
was thinking of kind of the rural urban
divide at that time right so like you
got the regenerative braking
right you can make the truck lighter you
can keep it local right you don't get
any benefit from that you know hybrid
electric in the
uh
on the rural highway you want
aerodynamics right
there you want low rolling resistance
tires and these super aerodynamic sleek
trucks right where we know with
off-the-shelf technology today we could
double the fuel economy more than double
the fuel economy of the typical truck in
that highway segment
if we segmented the duty cycle right and
so in the urban environment you want a
clean burning truck so you're not giving
kids asthma you want it lighter so it's
not destroying those those less
strong pavements right you're not you
can make tighter turns you don't need a
sleeper cab because the driver you know
hopefully is getting home at night right
in the long haul you want that super
aerodynamic stuff now that doesn't get
you anything in the city and in fact it
causes all kinds of problems because you
turn too tight you crunch up all the
aerodynamics that connect the the
tractor and the trailer
so
the idea that i had was like okay what
if we deliberately segmented it like
what if we created these drop lots
outside cities
where
you know a local city driver who's paid
by the hour kind of runs these trailers
out once they're loaded you know it
doesn't sit there and wait while it's
being loaded they drop off a trailer
they go pick up one that's loaded they
run it out when it's loaded they call
them and they just run them out there
and stage them it's like an uber driver
but for uh truckloads yeah and we have
like intermodal we have like we have
basically this would be the equivalent
of like rail to truck inner motor right
so you put it on the rail and then you
know a truck trucker picks it up and
delivers it right so instead of having
the rail you'd have these super
aerodynamic hopefully platoons or or
what was at the time was called long
combination vehicles which is basically
two trailers connected together right
because this is like a huge productivity
gain right um and then instead of that
driver like me i would pick up something
in upstate new york drive to michigan
drive to alabama you know drive to
wisconsin drive to florida you know i
get home every two weeks if i'm just
running that you know um
that double
trailer i might be able to go back and
forth from chicago to detroit right take
two trailers there pick up two trailers
going back right and be home every night
now the problem with that at the time or
one of them was you know
bridge weights so you can't not all
bridges can handle
that um that much weight on them they
can't handle these doubles right and
some places can some places can't so
this platooning idea was happening at
the same time and we ended up on the
same panel and the founders were like
hey so what's it like to follow really
close behind another truck which was
kind of the the stage that they were at
was like you know what's that experience
going to be like and i was like
truckers aren't going to like it you
know i mean that that's just like the
cardinal rule is following distance like
that's the one you really shouldn't
violate right um and and when you're out
on the road like you have that trucker
like right on your ass you know people
remember that they don't remember the
99.9
of truckers that are not on their ass
you know like they they they're very
careful about that but when you're when
the trucks are really close together
there's benefits in terms of
aerodynamics so that's the the idea so
like if you
want to get some benefits of uh a
platoon you want them to be close
together but you're saying that's very
uncomfortable for truckers yeah so i
mean i think that ended up at the i mean
peloton i think is sort of winding down
um their their work on this um and
i think that ended up being still an
open question like and i had a chance to
interview a couple drivers who um at
least one maybe two of which had
actually driven in their platoons um and
i got completely different experiences
um some of them were like it's really
cool you know i'm like in communication
with that other driver um you know i can
see on a screen what what's out out you
know the front of his truck um and then
somewhere like it's too close um and it
might be one of those things that's just
you know takes an adjustment to to sort
of get there
so you get the aerodynamic advantage
which which you know saves fuel um
there's some problems though right so
you know you're getting that aerodynamic
advantage because there's a low pressure
system in front of that following truck
but the the engine is designed with
higher pressure um feeding that engine
right so are sort of adjustments that
you need to make and you know still the
benefits are are there
that's one scenario and that's just the
automation of that acceleration and
braking
starsky which um you know
probably a lot of your listeners heard
heard about
um was working on another scenario which
was
you know to solve that local problem was
going to do teleoperation right uh sort
of remote piloting um
i had a chance to you know sort of watch
watch them do that it was you know they
they drove a truck in florida from um
from san francisco in one of their
office offices uh that was that was
really interesting
you